aujourd'hui je voudrais parler de
compréhension c'est un truc absolument
fascinant avec des implications dans
tous les sens il est étonnamment
difficile de répondre à la question
qu'est ce que comprendre quelque chose
cette fois encore je ne prétends pas et
si présenter une preuve validé par la
communauté scientifique
j'exprime simplement une opinion il est
tout à fait possible que je sois à côté
de la plaque ça commence avec l'histoire
d'un prof de physique aux états unis qui
fait rentrer des élèves dans sa classe
et leur montre un radiateur à côté
duquel se trouve une grande plaque de
métal
il leur demande de toucher la plaque et
les élèves découvrent à leur grand
étonnement que la plaque et froide côté
radiateur est chaude de l'autre côté il
leur demande
à votre avis pourquoi certains disent
c'est une histoire de conviction
d'autres tentes c'est la conduction
thermique ou c'est une question
d'alliage de l'acier pas un ne donne la
bonne réponse mais au fait c'est quoi la
même réponse bien de réponse est je ne
sais pas parce qu'en fait le prof a
retourné la plaque 30 secondes avant que
les élèves n'entrent dans ma classe le
problème c'est que le système éducatif
tend à récompenser les élèves s'ils
donnent la bonne réponse mais on ne
vérifie pas s'ils ont effectivement
compris la réponse qu'il donne on ne se
préoccupe pas assez de savoir si l'on a
pris dans cette histoire les élèves
fouilles dans leur mémoire et essaye de
trouver ce que le prof d'entendre un peu
comme s'il cherchait à deviner son mot
de passe
mais s'il avait effectivement compris la
convection ou la conduction thermique
il n'aurait pas pu donner cette réponse
car s'éloigne n'explique pas ces
phénomènes bien le contraire croire en
quelque chose ça suppose de s'attendre à
ce que certains phénomènes soit possible
et surtout parce que certains phénomènes
soit impossible je vais faire une vidéo
là-dessus bientôt ce travers du système
éducatif ne s'arrête pas à l'école ce
rapport à la connaissance perdure à
l'âge adulte on pourrait faire une
petite analogie on peut aller à la salle
de sport pour faire de la gonflette se
sculpter un corps d'apollon il se
regarder dans le miroir pendant des
heures on peut aussi aller à la salle
pour travailler quelque chose en
particulier sa force pure son
explosivité
sa puissance est appuyé autre exemple on
peut modifier sa voiture pour que la
leyre plus sportive en ajoutant un
aileron un bas de caisse ou je ne sais
quoi j'y connais rien en voiture mais on
peut aussi faire ce qu'on appelle de la
préparation
auteur on ne touche pas tellement à son
allure mais la voiture est devenue
beaucoup plus performante
c'est pareil avec la culture et le
savoir on peut lire de la philosophie ou
de la littérature on peut aller au
cinéma au théâtre voir des expositions
si ce n'est pas dans le but de
développer une puissance spécifique il
ya de bonnes chances que ce soit
l'équivalent du bodybuilding
c'est la culture pour la culture tient
d'ailleurs vous savez comment ça
s'appelle un français un petit buteur
c'est un culturiste si un bodybuilder ne
fait que de la gonflette et oublient de
travail et sa souplesse ses tendons et
si ligaments il est possible que ses
gros muscles l'empêchent d'être vraiment
performant de la même manière avoir la
mémoire pleine de références culturelles
si on ne travaille pas son raisonnement
ça peut faire obstacle à la pensée ça
peut rendre plus difficile l'accès à une
réflexion juste dans son abécédaire de
l'eau se dit qu'il n'est pas quelqu'un
de cultivé parce qu'il n'a pas de savoir
de réserve
ce que j'apprends dit il je la prends
pour un travail et ensuite j'oublie tout
c'est un peu la même idée
on peut prendre une dernière métaphore
avec l'informatique on pourrait se
contenter de l'eau est par défaut et
ajouté plein de logiciels gourmands
remplit deux fonctions dont on ne se
sert jamais ça va ralentir l'ordinateur
ou alors on choisit un modèle open
source
on apprend un programme aeae on conçoit
notre façon optimale apprendre à
apprendre apprendre à comprendre c'est
reprogrammer son logiciel mental c'est
mettre les mains dans le cambouis pour
ce que stomisés et se rendre plus
performant même si souvent plus
performant peut aussi dire plus prudent
dans l'ordre de la pensée très peu de
gens ont cette relation à la culture
pourquoi ce désir d'engranger du savoir
sans but précis
peut-être que c'est pour briller dans
l'espoir et pour démontrer sa
supériorité culturelle
peut-être mais je crois qu'il ya des
raisons plus profondes d'abord j'ai
l'impression qu'on aime les conclusions
on aime ce qui donne un sentiment de
maîtrise c'est ainsi je le sais je peux
considérer cela comme acquis
toute expérience de propriété
d'acquisition et rassurante pour
l'humain ça lui donne l'impression de
contrôler sa vie un peu plus c'est
exactement ce que nous offre une
conclusion de la clôture ça a des
limites
donc ça rend l'idée plus facile à
manipuler et puis la conclusion c'est la
fin et on a tendance à penser que c'est
la fin qui donne de la valeur aux
trajets
on retrouve ça dans cette drôle
d'expression rira bien qui rira le
dernier
comme si le rire finale avait une valeur
supplémentaire on pourrait se demander
si deux amis se font des farces vaut-il
mieux rire beaucoup en premier ou rire
un peu en dernier bon là je digresse
mais cette question n'apparaît pas tout
à fait sans intérêt ce que je voudrais
interrogés c'est une possible tendance
en fait à survaloriser les conclusions
comme si la connaissance à laquelle on
aboutit était la seule chose qui compte
je reconnais bien sûr que la conclusion
est parfois un nouveau point de départ
mais la valeur de cette nouvelle quête
pourrait bien à son tour être projeté
dans une finalité externe halak est
elle-même en fait on pourrait dire ceci
une pensée c'est une vague et la
conclusion c'est l'écumé de la vague
l'aboutissement le problème c'est qu'à
moins d'être un expert en vagues
il est très difficile de distinguer
légumes d'une grande vague puissante de
légumes d'une petite vaguelette pourri
se ressemblent énormément et c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça je crois que des
pseudos intellectuels peuple les médias
ils font beaucoup d'efforts pour
présenter une écume choquant facile à
retenir et cela fait écran à la vague
qui en est la cause
si l'objectif est de comprendre quelque
chose au sens où contrairement aux
élèves du début de la vidéo on serait
capable de l'appliquer pour résoudre soi
même des problèmes alors sans doute
faut-il s'attacher à comprendre les
étapes de la démonstration et ou
comprendre le contexte au sein duquel
émerge la proposition ça permet de
découvrir un la structure même du
raisonnement et de la situation qu'il a
fait naître ce qu'il ne faut pas
négliger car on pourrait dire que la
hauteur des vagues dépend de
l'environnement où celle-ci se forme
certains seront peut-être tentés
d'ajouter qu'il ne s'agit pas seulement
de prendre la vague mais de savoir quel
rivage elle peut nous porter et en effet
il ne parlait pas très périlleux
d'avancer l'hypothèse selon laquelle les
pensées et les raisonnements parce
qu'ils produisent une vision du monde
nous emmène vers des modes d'existence
associé à cette vision et ses modes
peuvent avoir des tonalités très
différentes
tous ne sont pas aussi joyeux aussi
serein ou aussi altruiste par exemple il
ya évidemment un nombre colossal de
paramètres possibles
mais attention à l'heure à ne pas
instrumentaliser à nouveau la vague au
profit de la destination
je ne dis pas que la destination n'a
aucune importance évidemment qu'elle est
tout à fait central dans la pensée je
veux seulement laissé entendre qu'il est
possible qu'on sous-estimé l'importance
de la manière avec laquelle on s'y rend
ou pour le dire autrement la relation
qu'on entretient avec une pensée ou
une croyance dépend de la manière avec
laquelle on l'a adopté et on à défendre
à d'ailleurs différemment auprès
d'autrui selon les cas parce que le
trajet compte plus qu'on ne le pense
et pourtant c'est pas les clichés qui
manquent donc développé une culture
rationnelle de la pensée cela
supposerait dans ce cas d'évaluer les
raisonnements 1
du point de vue de l'objectif c'est à
dire selon que le raisonnement est
efficace ou non
relativement à la fonction qu'on lui
donne et 2 du point de vue du moyen lui
même c'est à dire indépendamment de
l'objectif s'est interrogée la manière
qu'on a choisie pour poser et résoudre
les problèmes cela fait intervenir entre
autres des questions d'échelle
est ce que je me préoccupe de penser le
microscopique ou le macroscopique la
partie où le tout le rapport au langage
est ce que j'emploie le sens commun est
ce que j'essaie de produire une nouvelle
signification ou le degré de
ressemblance visé et c'est le moyen que
l'on choisit pour penser le monde a un
coût et une rentabilité propre qui
dépendent d'un autre type d'objectif
cela veut dire qu'il faut se demander
dans l'évaluation des conséquences du
raisonnement sur quoi est ce que mon
regard se concentrent les conséquences
explicite c'est à dire les implications
théoriques de la proposition
si l'argument est valide si l'hypothèse
est crédible si les données confirment
ou infirment très bien c'est normal mais
est ce que je regarde aussi les
implications éthiques de la proposition
au sens large du terme éthique c'est à
dire tout ce qui tient à l'ethos à la
manière qu'on a de conduire sa vie
encore une fois la proposition doit être
pensé en termes de spect ou de
proportion je n'encourage pas abandonner
l'évaluation des conclusions mais à se
demander la place qu'on donne à
l'évaluation du trajet dans l'abord d'un
raisonnement et je crois qu'il serait
souhaitable qu'un penseur n'explicite
pas seulement le résultat de son travail
mais également son choix de travailler
ainsi sur tel objet est de telle manière
c'est important pour la communication si
on ne s'attaque qu'aux conclusions
ça donne vite des discussions de sourds
absolument stérile on ne peut pas
vraiment comprendre une position si on
ne sait pas ce qui fait qu'on a fini par
l'adopter
pour en revenir au surf ce qui est
chouette c'est qu'un surfeur ne pense
pas être l'auteur de son ride il sait
qu'il est le coauteur du ride
parce qu'il est impossible de faire un
bon ride sans une bonne vague c'est bien
pour ça d'ailleurs qu'il se réunisse
tous là où il ya les meilleures vagues
et bien j'ai l'impression que c'est
pareil avec la pensée si on ne regarde
que la conclusion
on peut avoir du mal à saisir ce que la
pensée implique pour savoir le mode de
vie qui a résolument suppose il faut
surfer la vague et donc il faut
fréquenter un peu l'océan pour apprendre
à distinguer d'à côté les murs les
pensées qui sont des défis en même temps
que devrait tremplin mentaux et de
l'autre les petites vaguelettes de la
côte d'azur qui ne permette rien du tout
apprendre à penser c'est donc aussi
apprendre à sentir les vagues auxquels
on a affaire pour savoir si on veut les
surfs et je sais que ça ne semble pas
très rigoureux mais je crois que de
dangers auxquels on pense quand je dis
les choses comme ça danger qu'il faudra
aborder spécifiquement dans une vidéo à
part bientôt puisque c'est les dangers
liés à toute diffusion de connaissances
ou d'idées je crois que ce danger
diminue considérablement quand on prend
conscience
une fois qu'on s'engage à surfer qu
aucune pensée n'est absolument sans
conséquences idéologiques toute
production de savoirs aussi neutres ce
soit elle projettera une image de
l'homme plutôt qu'une autre
et celle ci aura des effets politiques
on peut déclarer que ce n'était pas la
nôtre attention ça ne change pas
grand-chose parce qu'on pourrait
répondre
nul n'est censé se désintéresser des
conséquences morales de ses actions cela
suppose bien sûr d'interroger entre
autres la différence entre les approches
réductionniste d'une part et holistique
d'autre part toutes deux ont leur
puissance et leur limite et sans doute
est il souhaitable de savoir basculer de
l'un à l'autre selon les contextes
pour schématiser très grossièrement ce
que le réductionnisme gagner en
précision il le perd en termes de sens
c'est comme avoir l'oeil sur l'atome
sans voir la molécule dont il fait
partie ce que la vision holistique gagne
en termes de vue d'ensemble de capacité
à produire du sens moral et métaphysique
disons elle le perd en rigueur et en
solidité
elle permet des avancées parfois douteux
et peine à faire consensus même en son
sens mais la question du consensus c'est
un vrai bordel
et comme disait on verra ça plus
précisément plus tard toujours est il
que si la question de départ était avez
vous compris la réponse pourrait être la
suivante comprendre un énoncé c'est
comprendre ce qu'il dit c'est comprendre
le raisonnement qui permet son
énonciation c'est comprendre le contexte
qui permet l'émergence du raisonnement
et c'est comprendre les implications
éthiques et politiques de l'énoncé
relativement à ce qu'il dit c'est à dire
les culs et la manière de penser c'est à
dire la vague
tout ça pour dire que toute croyance
s'inscrit dans un système de valeurs et
qu'il est impératif de l'interroger
consciemment ce qui suppose de regarder
en arrière sur quel système de valeurs
je m'appuie et en avant quel système de
valeurs est-ce que je promets la règle
d'or du patient zéro ce pourrait être
mes croyances détermine mes actions et
mes actions ont des conséquences sur le
monde il faudrait ajouter au delà de la
seule conscience qu'on en a ça veut donc
dire qu'il faut interroger ses croyances
et les effets qu'elles ont sur le monde
tous les concepts et toutes les valeurs
ont une histoire politique c'est à dire
qu'ils sont liés à des et hausse à des
façons de vivre des manières de
concevoir le monde et la place d'autrui
il serait naïf de croire que la valeur
des vérités échappent à ce constat elle
aussi s'est construite dans le temps et
notre rapport à elle est intriguée elle
au désir de transcendance autant qu'à
nos rêves de pureté
ce n'est pas parce qu'on s'occupe de
vérité que notre point de vue n'est pas
situé on pourrait ainsi présenté la
chose toute pensée doit tenir sur deux
jambes pour deux prises de conscience
d'abord qu'une croyance prêtant toujours
être rationnel il faut donc interroger
la solidité des arguments qui la
soutiennent et 2 qu'une croyance n'est
jamais neutre est toujours en relation
avec un système de valeurs soit une
relation d'approbation soit une relation
de refus aussi une croyance promeut un
certain nombre d'attitudes tacitement
liée à sa prise de position relative aux
dix systèmes de valeurs
toute action a une portée politique plus
ou moins directement ou plus ou moins
grande selon le cas évidemment mais il
serait naïf voire malhonnête de croire
que l'on peut y échapper
c'est tout pour aujourd'hui à bientôt